ve hayatının ilk yalnız seyahatine 12
yaşında altı hafta Amerika yapmış biri
olarak aslında ne kadar özgür ve
keşfetme aşk ruhum oldu Çok küçük yaşta
ortaya çıkmıştı İstanbul'dan direkt uçuş
olmayan aletin esata yaptım
yolculuklarım da bazen bavulların
kaybedildi farklı kuyruklarda farklı
muameleler gördüm Hatta bazen s terörist
onu sormaya bile çekildim Fakat bunların
hiçbiri dünyada her milletten insanın
farklı tanımak sız birbirine bağlayan
bilecek tek ortak nokta olan sanat aşkım
öldürmeye yetmedi
2000'li Sabah uyku tulumunda yardımı
uyanıyorum Kilis edeyim abi ayın
başlamak üzere arkadaşlarım hemen
hazırlanıp şoförle gidiyoruz deposu
dinlemeye başlıyoruz etrafına Bakıyorum
hiç birimizde o dine mensup değil mi
değiliz aslında birimizin Müslüman
birimiz Yahudi bilim Cindy oradayız
Çünkü saygı diyoruz çocuğu hiç kimse
hiçbir zararımız yok hata sözünü
bitiriyor tam gideceğiz derken içeri
birden bir imam bir haham ve biyo
giriyor ve sırayla bizim dinimizin
duaları okumaya başlıyorlar Evet hala
kilisenin içindeyiz kulağa Belki şaka
gibi geliyor Ama ben bunu hayatımı
değiştiren program sonrası olsa gittiğim
İlkyaz yine satın çok küçük bir şehrinde
gördüm ve o zaman anladım ki asla şu an
Dünya'da Yaşanan her şey insanların
inançlarını biraz zayıf nokta olarak
kullanıldığı bir güç yarışına dönmüş
bu sonra fıss 15 senedir her yıl düzenli
olarak gittiğim müzik dans bazı bir
sosyal yardım kaldı ve bu kamp gittiysen
İki günden annesini Ben geri dönmek
istiyorum diye ağlayan kızı bugün burada
bu kadar çılgını konuşabilecek cesarete
sahiplendi Aslında bu program on beş
ülkeden gelen çocukların kendi
geleneksel kostümleri şarkıları ve
dansları eşliğinde bunu oradaki diğer
çocukları öğreterek 3 hafta 90 dakikalık
Onbeşli barındıran bir şey çıkartıyor
ortaya emin olun ki biçiminin İbranice
ya da bir arnavutun İngilizce şarkı
söylemesi çok kolay bir şey değil Hele
ki genelinde saniye hiç çıkmamış
çocuklarla 90 dakikalık bir şey
hazırlamak imkansız ya duyulabilir ama
her sabah kalktığınızda duvarınızda
nasıl Mandala magazin sözleriyle
uyandığımız bir yerde imkansız diye bir
şey yer yok Bunu Tamam üç haftada ise
hazırladığımız bu 90 dakikalık Show
yaklaşık 30-35 tane olmak üzere
yetimhanelerde huzurevlerinde En
ve hastanelerde tiyatrolarda ve
parklarla yapıyoruz Aslında buradaki
asıl olay yaptığımız Show değil daha
sonra 30 lira geçirdiğimiz vakit
izleyenler imiz çok özel bir Kitle ve
biz gelir beklemeksizin yaptığımız için
bunu tek istediğim şey o kitlenin göz
Yüzündeki gülümseme ve hatırlamış ikisi
Aslında başta 12 yaşındaki çocuklarına
kadar rahat olmaları gerektiğini empoze
etmeye Çalışsak da evet de geliyorlar Ya
onların üzersem ya ondan istemeden
kırarsam gibi düşüncelere katılıyorlar
Ben de başta öyleydim ama Zaman geçtikçe
gereken rahatla uğraşmayı bırak
sandıklar güzel görmeye başlamış onlarla
arkadaş olmuş oluyorsun
bu mesela 2014 yılında Kamber Kit olarak
geri Gittiğimde her sene düzenli olarak
gittiğinizde engeller bakımevinde tekrar
gittik ilk seninle tanıştığım zihinsel
engelli bir kadın vardı Tara ve ikinci
sene gittiğimde nedenle paylaşmak
istemediği bir sebepten ötürü kör
olduğunu öğrendim odasına gittim kendimi
tanıttım O da beni hatırladın oraya
gelmem onu çok mutlu ettiğini söyledi
daha sonra birlikte etkinlik masalarında
etkinlikler yaptık vakit geçirdik
giderken ve Görüşürüz derken tekrar
gelmemi istediğini ve benimle tanıştı
için çok memnun olduğunu söyledi Ben
orada başka bir insanlara yardım eli
uzatmanın onlarla vakit geçirmenin başka
hiçbir hisse karşılaştırmaya cağını
Anladım Ve ben bunu sadece 13 yaşında
anladıysan yüzümüze nasıl Hala umursamaz
insan sayısı bu kadar korkunç derecede
fazla kalabiliyor
abone ol
bu 21 yüzyılda Metropol ipi şehirde
yaşayan Haçlı cebine konulan yemeğini
hazırlanan ve bazen de çevresine gibi
çok haberden Belki de habersiz olan
birçok çocuk gibiydim Ben de bu kamptaki
kurallardan biri bir odada kalan
herkesin farklı milletlerden olmak
zorunda olması mesela 2015 senesinde
benim odamda bir Amerikalı İtalyan
biçimleri bir Türk kalıyorduk günümüz
politikasının daha çok açmam Gerekirse
bir ortadoğulu bir Amerikalı bir Asyalı
ve bir Avrupalı kalıyorduk yetişkinler
dünyasında böyle bir şey Belki de
İmkansız ama çocuklar için öyle değil
çünkü çocuklar bizi bizlere
farklılıklarımızın bilgiler bütün
yapabileceğini kanıtlayabilecek tek şey
aslında Çünkü onlar altı hafta boyunca
sizin uyku tulumu muzu çamaşır Annenizi
Odamızı her şeyinizi Paylaştığınız
insanlar Peki kültürel farklılıklarımız
Biz Üstün ya da aşağıda kıyamazken
büyüyünce ne oluyor ve ne değişiyor
Balta hafta çocuğun Amerika'ya o
ama söyleme yolları mahallelerden bir de
çocuklarını telefonsuz tabletsiz
bilgisayarsız Yani kısacası teknoloji
ile bağlantılı her türlü Şeyden Uzak
yollama larını istiyoruz başta kulağa
çok ilginç ve imkansız duyulsa da emin
olun ki bir süre sonra biz Milan var
bile teknolojinin varlığını unutuyoruz
Çünkü insanlar Kısa bir süre için olsa
da dışarı çıkıyor sohbet ediyor spor
yapıyor oyun oynuyor Yani normalde
yaşaması gerektiği gibi yaşıyor
kendinize olsun sormamız gereken şeyse
Biz ne oldu da teknolojiye bu kadar
bağımlı ve muhtaç bir hale geldik
bu Dumanlı ve Aslında muhtaçların günlük
hayattaki göstergesini 2016 yazında
Kamber kilidi olarak gittiğinde Anladım
O yaz biraz talihsiz di mi gittiğimiz
haftadan önceki dişimi kırdım ne
yapacağımı bilmiyordum canım yanıyordu
ve panik an halleri telefonunu ver kutu
kimseyi arayamıyorum sesleri yanına
gittim beni sakinleştiriciler neler
yapmam gerektiğini söylediler ve artık
bugün kampın direktörleri ile birlikte
ailemi aradım ve asla beş hafta boyunca
dişsiz gelmeyeceğim konusunda diretti
Meğer aranızda Amerika'ya gitmiş ve
orada sağlık problemi yaşamış biri varsa
Amerika'daki sağlık sektöründeki korkunç
fiyatları şu an duymuş olabilirsiniz Ben
duymamıştım ve bana şöyle özetledi
Amerika'da dişim yaptıracağım parayla
Türkiye'ye gelir dişimi yaptırır geri
dönerim hala daha ucuz tutar bunu
duyduktan sonra biraz elbiseler semde
aynaya her baktığımda neden dişim
yaptırmam gerektiğini tekrar atıyordum
son
bu elimde lan suyla konulmuş kırık dişin
ve hiçbir şey aramayacağım Lan bir haber
oldum sağlık sigortalı birlikte dişçiye
gittim işte dişim yaptı korku korku
böyle ödeme aslanı masasına gittim
arkamdan Dişçi geldi ve bana ödemem
gereken hiçbir şey olmadığını söyledi
Ben neden olduğunu anlamadım Emin
misiniz Neden böyle yapıyorsun diye
sordum varsa bana ülkemde Türkiye'de
yaşanan olaylar için çok üzgün olduğunu
ve yapabileceği her türlü yardımın onu
Minnet duy duracağını söyledi ben
inanamadım ve sizin için ne yapabilirim
diye tekrar tekrar sorduğumda bana kargo
ile kutu lokum yolla dedi ben lokumları
yolladım ve ona binlerce kez teşekkür
ederek piknikten ayrıldım daha sonra
düşündüm Bir insan bir zanneden böyle
bir şey yapar bir hasta bir hastaya Bir
doktor bir Amerikalı bir Türk bir erkeğe
bir kız gibi kafamda bir sürü kalıp
kurdum ve o zaman anladım ki aslında
hepimiz yıllardır med
bu bilinçaltımızı soktu etiketlerin
mahkum olmuşuz ve 15 yaşında bir kız
bile böyle düşünme yönelmiş aslında
o Nur dünyanın bize Aslında gösterilmiş
gel simülasyonu gibi dünya sorunlarınız
mesela Özel bir Öğle yemeğimiz var orada
okeson çok sen baştan anca stafler
çocuklara dünyadaki açlık sorununa kadar
büyük ve korkunç boyutta olduğu ile
ilgili bir sunum yapıyorlar ve ardından
kura çekiyoruz bu kuralı 3 sınıflara b&c
Bunlar dünyadaki mavi sınıfları temsil
ediyorlar zengin ortaya fakir olarak a
kampın yüzde ikilik bir kısmı masada
oturuyor sandalyede çatal bıçağı var
porsiyonu Çok büyük ve suyu da sınırsız
ve kampın yaklaşık yüzde onluk kadar bir
kısmın masada oturmuyor sadece
sandalyesi var çubuğu çağda yok Sadece
çatal var porsiyonu biraz daha küçük ve
su yarım bardak
o CS dünyadaki fakir kısmı temsil ediyor
ve 188 lik bir kısım kamptaki yerde
oturuyor çatal bıçağı yok suyu yok ve
kese kağıdından çok küçük miktarda
pirinç diyor Biz bu üç grubu aynı
yemekhane koyarak Herkes birbirini
görebileceğim şekilde çocuklara
farkındalık kazandırıyoruz herkes
aslında bir birine yemek vermek istiyor
kimse gözünden arkadaşını açıklamasına
dayanamıyor ama maalesef bu alışverişi
önleyerek onlar alsa dünyanın bu konuda
ne kadar da acımasız olduğunu kanıtlamış
oluyoruz
Ya aslında burada bir öğretmen şey şu
Biz küçükken bu kadar merhametli iken Ne
oldu bu kadar acımasız bir hale geldik
o lan borcum ansızın en büyük göstergesi
kendim yaşayarak gördüm bu yaz giderken
yolculukta aktarmalı gidiyorum Dediğim
gibi 17 saatin sonra sonra Amerika'ya
varmışım Çok yorgunum ama o sene lütfen
yükselmiş saf olmuşum da çok
heyecanlıyım aynı zamanda pasaport
konserine geldim Karşımda beyaz kilolu
yaşlı bir Amerikalı bana önce bütün
soruları sormaya başladım şey ne
yapacaksın Nerede kalıyorsun gibi daha
sonra verdim Her bu cevaptan sonra bana
da izleyici bir soruyla geri döndü biraz
böyle Bilgisayarda bir şeyler yaptıktan
sonra şeklini çağırdı beni kastım
servise götürmesini söyledi Ben hiçbir
şey anlamadım ama mecbur olduğu için
takip ettim kalsın sonrası girdiğimde
içeride Şirin Suriyeli Afganistanlı gibi
bir sürü dünyada ayarlı saçmalıklarına
maruz kalmaktan insanları gördüm 5-10
dakika bekledikten sonra beni tekrar
yanına çağırdı tekrar aynı için soruları
sordum daha sonra
bu olmak istediklerine geldi mi PKK ile
ilişkin var mı Hiçbir tarafta masaj
şahit oldun mu ailenden herhangi biri
Suriye'ye gittim ya da orada bulunuyor
gibi onlarca soru sordu Ben bunların
hepsini içten çok büyük bir stres ve ama
dişten çok büyük bir soğuk kalmadı
dikkatlice yanıtladım daha sonra Gidip
babamla gel dedi tam çıkacakken
telefonunu ki telefonun kilidi açık
bırak dedi Neden diye sorunca da bana
Sesini yükseltme acele acele etmem
gerektiğini söyle hiçbir şey sorgulama
hakkım olmadığını söyledi Bu oğlumu alıp
geldim ben ayrı sorgu odasına aldılar
iki adam eldivenlerini taktı ve karışık
bulunduğu aradılar karşında diğer
görevli telefonla uygulanan bulunan her
şey bu uygulamaya girdi mesajlar
Instagram WhatsApp akıllı gelecek mail
Gmail Fotoğraf her şey ne aradıklarını
bilmiyorum ve belki de şu zaman
Öğreneceğim ama sonra bu yaptıkların
hepsini bitirip pasaport videomda basıp
beni yolladılar ha
bir şey soramadım hiçbir şey öğrenemedim
ve belki de hayatımda stresi kırk beş
Dakikasını yaşamıştım o zaman anladım ki
belki de pasaportumun üzerinde onların
gözünde Üstün biriken ibaret olsa hiç
şekilde bana bunları yaşatmazlar ve
belki de bunları günde kaç bir insan
yaşıyor ve sadece 16 yaşında bir kıza
bile böyle muamele yapılıyorsa Başka
insanlara Daha ne kadar çirkinleri
yapılabilir bir ağaç yaşken eğilir sözü
çok güzel bir söz Çünkü küçükken ki
merhametliliği mizden Gülünce ki
acımasızlığı mıza kadar olan tüm düşerse
yaşadığımız her şey aslında dünyaya
sunduğumuz önyargı palavralardan ibaret
Dünyanın düzeni ve Birliği insanın
Birlik fikrini benimseyerek olur ve bu
fikir benimsemek için din dil ırk maddi
gibi her türlü farklı bir kenara
tutmalıyız ve acımasızlıkla ve merhamet
acımasızlık ları merhametliliği davullu
mı diye dönüştürmeliyiz Birbirimize
ulaşabileceğimiz bir çok yol var çünkü
hiçbir zaman konuşmak zorunda değiliz
dans edebiliriz şarkı söyleyebiliriz
yazılar yazabilir tiyatro yapabiliriz
bunları dünyaya Ben bir değiştireceğim
demeden yapmalıyız Çünkü ben 12 yaşında
Akşamları oldu arkadaşlarıyla sohbet
edip çamaşırhanede çamaşır makineleri
nasıl çalıştırması gerektiğini düşünüp
inşallah da bulaşık kurası Çıkmam diyor
umarken kendimi birden çocukların
pasaport ve paralarına sahip çıkan
gerektiğinde onları dünya sorunlarını
anlatıp onların dizlerine düştüklerinde
pansuman yapan biri olarak buldum
kendimi
ve sanat bir insanın dünyasını
değiştirir ve hiçbir zaman unutmamalıyız
ki dünyadaki görmek istediğiniz değişim
olmalıyız Çünkü bir sürecini yönetmek
her zaman bizim elimizde Teşekkür ederim
bu